Bonjour à toute et à tous, bienvenue sur ma chaîne !
Aujourd'hui, je suis très heureux de vous présenter une vidéo un peu spéciale...
Dans quelques jours, vous le savez peut-être c’est la journée mondiale sans tabac,
alors pour ce numéro de “Dis Jamy” et bien je suis épaulé je suis avec Marine Lorphelin. Bonjour Marine.
Bonjour Jamy, merci de m'accueillir je suis ravie d'être là.
Alors Marine, tout le monde te connaît, tu as été miss France en 2013, mais si tu es là aujourd'hui c'est d'abord et avant tout parce que tu es interne en médecine générale
et qu'ensemble nous allons passer en revue les fausses bonnes raisons que l’on invoque pour ne pas arrêter de fumer.
Avec l’Institut national du cancer, nous vous avons demandé de nous donner, sur les réseaux épicurieux vos fausses bonnes raisons et on n'a pas été déçus !
C'est vrai Jamy, vous avez été nombreux à partager vos excuses et vous avez été créatifs !
Mais aujourd'hui on va se concentrer sur celles qui reviennent le plus souvent.
Aller c'est parti !
Première bonne raison qui revient souvent, sur la quantité de cigarettes fumées, ceux qui pensent que “fumer quelques cigarettes par jour”
ou “uniquement en soirée” ne serait pas dangereux.
“Je ne fume que quelques cigarettes par jour, ce n’est pas grave”
C'est vrai qu’on entend souvent dire ça.
Oui on l'entend très souvent, et c’est vraiment une fausse idée : dès la première cigarette, la consommation de tabac comporte des risques pour la santé.
À la première bouffée, les goudrons contenus dans la fumée de cigarette vont se déposer dans les poumons,
le monoxyde de carbone se fixer sur les globules rouges et les substances irritantes vont inflammer des bronches.
J’ajoute, qu’avec cette première bouffée, la nicotine peut engendrer une dépendance ; elle stimule ce qu’on appelle le circuit de la récompense dans le cerveau.
En effet, la nicotine vient se fixer sur certains neurotransmetteurs. Ce sont ces molécules qui transmettent les messages entre les neurones,
et une fois qu’ils ont été activés, eh bien ils réclament en quelque sorte une dose supplémentaire.
Les fumeurs doivent aussi savoir que même fumer occasionnellement, entre 6 et 10 cigarettes dans le mois,
eh bien cela augmente de 82% leur taux de mortalité toutes maladies confondues par rapport à ceux qui ne fument pas.
Et pourquoi ?
À cause justement de l’ensemble des toxiques qu’ils ingèrent…
Alors on connaît tous de gros fumeurs qui, régulièrement, essayent de diminuer leur consommation de cigarettes.
D’ailleurs, quand ils y arrivent, ils sont très fiers, et ils ont bien raison.
Le problème, c’est que dès qu’ils ont un souci, leur consommation recommence à augmenter.
Et c’est bien dommage, car on sait que les risques de cancers sont plus liés à la durée de la consommation du tabac qu’à la quantité de cigarettes fumées
Et, il faut rappeler que le tabac est impliqué dans le cancer du poumon, certes, mais aussi dans 16 autres cancers.
Fumer longtemps est plus dangereux que fumer beaucoup sur une courte période.
D’ailleurs, le Centre International de Recherche contre le Cancer a montré qu'un bénéfice significatif de l'arrêt du tabac durant une longue période,
a été observé pour tous les cancers majeurs associés au tabagisme.
Alors, pour ne pas décourager les bonnes volontés, disons que réduire sa consommation quotidienne, c’est un premier pas vers l’arrêt définitif.
Tout à fait Jamy, et c’est le message positif qu’on va garder. Mais le plus simple, c’est encore de ne jamais commencer.
Il y a aussi ceux qui fument depuis de nombreuses années, et qui se disent  :
“Je fume depuis trop longtemps, ça ne sert à rien de m’arrêter maintenant”.
Beaucoup de fumeurs s’imaginent que lorsqu’on a pas mal fumé et passé un certain âge, ça ne sert plus à rien.
En fait, on peut leur répondre que le bon âge, c’est quand c’est possible.
Tu le sais Jamy, ce n’est jamais facile de s’arrêter. En pratique, c’est quand on se sent prêt !
Pour augmenter ses chances d’y arriver, il faut donc déjà en avoir réellement envie et ça, ça dépend de chacun. Surtout, il ne faut pas hésiter à se faire aider !
Oui, la motivation est essentielle. Et si on arrête, on peut vraiment parler de réussite. Et on en tire un réel bénéfice que l’on ait 30, 40 ou 60 ans.
Oui, tu as tout à fait raison. Et les études le démontrent, ce bénéfice est immédiat.
Une seule journée sans tabac suffit déjà à faire baisser la tension artérielle.
En deux jours, le monoxyde de carbone est évacué de l’organisme et la capacité de transport de l’oxygène dans le sang est multipliée par deux.
Après une semaine d’arrêt, les capacités pulmonaires augmentent de façon significative.
Pour la nicotine, le syndrome de manque disparaît en deux à trois semaines.
Il y a un autre effet immédiat Jamy quand on arrête de fumer, c’est le retour du goût. Et avec lui, le plaisir de manger, et d’apprécier des bons petits plats.
Donc quand vous arrêtez de fumer, pensez à avoir une bonne hygiène de vie, mangez équilibré et avec des produits non transformés.
Ce point est essentiel, Marine. Je parlais il y a quelques instants de l’effet addictogène de la nicotine. Mais ce n’est pas le seul.
Elle a aussi un effet coupe-faim et on sait très bien que les risques de dénutrition sont un vrai souci pour les fumeurs.
Et c’est bien pour cette raison qu’il faut faire de la pédagogie.
Car si le tabac est mauvais pour la santé de chacun,
les hommes, les femmes, les jeunes, les vieux.
Il est la première cause évitable de décès par cancer. Il comporte des risques d’autant plus spécifiques quand on prend de l’âge.
Et là, tu fais sûrement allusion aux maladies cardiovasculaires, dont les risques augmentent avec l’âge.
Et c’est vrai que si on ajoute ceux liés au cancer, ça fait vraiment réfléchir.
Deux chiffres, Jamy : si on arrête de fumer à 65 ans, on peut gagner en moyenne 4 ans d’espérance de vie,
et si on arrête à 40 ans, 9 ans ans d’espérance de vie.
Mieux, si on arrête tôt, avant 35 ans, on sait que l’on va augmenter son espérance de vie en bonne santé et revenir quasiment à celle des non-fumeurs.
Alors rester jeune très longtemps, ça vaut franchement le coup, non ?
Clairement ! Et pour rester sur les jeunes, il y a une autre idée reçue, c’est que fumer autre chose que des cigarettes industrielles serait moins dangereux pour la santé.
“je fume des cigarettes roulées, c’est moins dangereux”
C’est vrai qu’elles ont du succès ces cigarettes roulées. Pour une raison très simple : elles coûtent moins cher.
Du coup, les fabricants s’en servent comme d’un produit d’appel qui serait, selon eux, sans vrai danger.
Alors que le niveau de combustion est bien plus élevé ce qui génère plus de substances toxiques.
Donc effectivement plus de substances cancérogènes.
Et oui comme la densité de tabac dans une cigarette roulée est bien moindre que dans une cigarette manufacturée, vous tirez plus sur la roulée.
Les cigarettes roulées sont tout aussi nocives pour la santé. Filtre ou pas, les risques de cancers de la sphère ORL,
c’est-à-dire de la bouche, du pharynx, du larynx sont aussi importants qu’avec les cigarettes classiques.
L’autre problème avec les cigarettes roulées, c’est leur mode de combustion. Comme elles sont souvent mal tassées, elles brûlent mal.
Il faut donc tirer davantage dessus, et comme elles s’éteignent régulièrement, et bien ceux qui fument ce type de cigarettes
sont obligés de les rallumer à chaque fois. Résultat : la fumée pénètre encore plus profondément dans les bronches.
Et oui Jamy, donc contrairement à l’idée reçue, les roulées sont aussi néfastes pour la santé que les cigarettes industrielles.
Elles ont pratiquement le même taux de nicotine et dégagent autant de goudron. Et elles ne sont pas plus naturelles, disons le.
La fumée de ces cigarettes est tout aussi cancérigène que celle des cigarettes classiques.
En fait, les éléments cancérigènes proviennent avant tout des feuilles de tabac qui se consument.
D’autant plus que pour éviter que le tabac sèche trop vite, les fabricants rajoutent des produits chimiques qu’on ne trouve pas dans les cigarettes industrielles.
Tiens, d’ailleurs, cet argument du tabac naturel me fait penser à la chicha, qui est très souvent présentée comme un produit sympa à partager entre amis.
Sauf que, même soi-disant filtré par l’eau, même aromatisé à la menthe ou autres choses...
Fumer la chicha pendant une heure est aussi nocif que fumer un à deux paquets de cigarettes.
C'est énorme !
Et c'était important de le dire, il y a les mêmes idées reçues sur les cigarettes fines.
Là aussi, il faut être très clair : elles sont tout aussi nocives que les autres : même taux de nicotine, même concentration en goudrons, et mêmes agents de texture.
Disons les choses autrement : le diamètre d’une cigarette n’a absolument rien à voir avec sa dangerosité.
Je le rappelle et c’est très important : le phénomène d’addiction à la nicotine est le même qu’avec une cigarette classique
C’est aussi valable pour la chicha, le cigare et, bien sûr, le cannabis. Et les conséquences sur la santé sont identiques.
Dernière chose, Jamy, sur le plan esthétique, ce n’est pas terrible non plus. C’est bête à dire mais, qui a envie de se retrouver avec dents jaunies par le tabac ?
En tout cas, pas moi
Ça ne t'irais pas.
Allez on passe à la dernière fausse bonne raison que l’on entend très souvent :
“Je fais du sport, pas besoin de m’arrêter de fumer”
Sous-entendu, ça compense. Et cette idée reçue est très répandue puisque 70 % des Français pensent que faire du sport nettoie les poumons.
Ah oui quand même !
Alors que c’est complètement faux. Une pratique sportive, même quotidienne, n’a absolument aucun effet sur les risques de cancer engendrés par le tabac.
Aucun sport ne permet d’éliminer les goudrons ni les 70 produits cancérigènes contenus dans la fumée de cigarette.
Au final, toutes ces substances sont impliquées dans 17 cancers différents.
Fumer va plutôt nuire aux performances sportives.
La combustion du tabac génère la production de monoxyde de carbone.
Et ce monoxyde de carbone gène le transport de l’oxygène dans l’organisme. Du coup, fumer, c’est plutôt dire adieu aux exploits sportifs.
Pire que ça, chaque année en France, plus de 1 000 personnes sont victimes de mort subite en lien avec une pratique sportive
Et parmi elles, bien évidemment, on retrouve aussi des fumeurs.
Alors cela semble paradoxal Jamy, on aurait tendance à penser que le sport pourrait améliorer les choses.
J’explique, toute activité physique intense exige un afflux de sang dans les muscles et cet afflux se fait par ce qu’on appelle la vasodilatation,
les vaisseaux sanguins s’ouvrent, se gonflent.
Mais le fait de tirer sur une cigarette a exactement un effet contraire, il resserre les vaisseaux. D’où le risque d’infarctus.
Et, si on ne peut vraiment pas s’en passer, il est important de suivre les recommandations des spécialistes qui disent :
jamais de cigarette une heure avant et deux heures après la pratique d’un sport.
On l’a bien compris, tabac et sport ne font pas bon ménage sauf si on se fixe un objectif : faire du sport pour se faire plaisir et aussi...
Ah oui, je te vois venir, peut-être pour arrêter de fumer !
Oui, dans ce sens, ça me va très bien.
On n'est pas là pour vous enfumer.
Et si vous voulez plus d'infos, rendez-vous sur le site e-cancer.fr
e-cancer.fr
C'est noté !